It ’s
good today.
It
's awkward, yeah, yeah, chan and the others have become masters, but please come in
. I'm making borin for a long time.
Ah ah
[applause]
dj nan
[music]
r child-sama,
there's
nothing,
you can
see
what's there,
you
say you're fortune-telling in this city
Shinobu  I heard that the master is making pudding as if he was obsessed with it, so
did you try it?
It was okay to paint it. What the hell is that
? Kyoto 3 Maybe this person will be our savior.
Blue
[Applause]
[Music]
banar
Hmm,
this is
selling lr
[Applause] Hmm
[Music]
Pudding is a mainland game standing pulling want Clean Nessia Decorator When I made Pudding,
I thought I'd kill it, but my
front teeth and front teeth  It's no good to whisper to make a puri and it's
no good. Miyakami I'm
attached to a person who feels casual.
There is a
real advantage, but
what a prayer this is, the
needle and the ghost were
so cute, weren't they?